we have breaking news overnight from the
supreme court in a five to four vote the
court refused to block a new texas law
that is the most restrictive abortion
law in the country chief justice john
roberts sided with the three liberals
the court's decision does not prevent it
from considering this case in the future
abortion rights supporters are
protesting the law calling it
unconstitutional ben tracy is outside
the supreme court ben good morning
vlad good morning in her dissent justice
sunya sotomayor called the court's
decision stunning she says this texas
law flouts nearly 50 years of federal
precedent but for now this texas law
which bans abortion after just six weeks
of pregnancy which is before most women
even know they're pregnant will remain
in place
[Applause]
abortion rights protesters at the texas
state capitol wednesday vowed to keep
fighting it is our right our individual
right to choose whether and when we're
going to have children across texas
abortion providers warn they may have to
close their doors and that the new law
will only lead to illegal and dangerous
abortions medical professionals
clergy members
especially that were around before roe v
wade in 73 can tell you the horror
stories the texas law bans abortion once
a so-called fetal heartbeat is detected
usually around six weeks it also
seemingly contradicts the supreme court
decision in roe v wade which guarantees
the right to abortion until fetal
viability which is about 22 to 24 weeks
the texas law also allows any private
citizen to sue someone helping a woman
get an abortion which includes doctors
clinic staff or even someone who drives
a woman to a clinic those who win a
lawsuit can be awarded at least 10
thousand dollars those are the ones who
are breaking the law who will be held
liable for their criminal activity
elizabeth graham is vice president of
texas right to life she says
anti-abortion advocates are now focused
on a mississippi case the supreme court
will hear this fall that could overturn
roe v wade the justices will either
have to strike down roe or say
that
life can be protected at this stage and
if life can be protected at this stage
we thereby concede that roe was a
judicial concoction and is now no longer
the law or the precedent of the land
now that mississippi law bans abortion
after 15 weeks of pregnancy and
supporters of that law are hoping the
conservative majority here at the
supreme court will use it to overturn
roe v wade tony ben thank you very much